- [GOPAL] All right, so
I'm gonna talk about,
I'm gonna talk about this,
this big challenge that we've seen
over the last year that you've read about.
I dunno how many of you saw
the MIT 95% pilots failed report.
If people come across that report,
there was like all the
news a few, few months ago.
And, and one of, one of our
kind of takes on the problem
is that the big issue is that,
that we're not really solving for
is this problem of AI being
confidently wrong, right?
And, and so what do I,
what do I mean by that?
AI has been around for
2, 2, 3 years now, right?
We've all been using it.
I, I don't think ever in the
history of any new technology,
it's gotten close to a billion users
in shut a, such a short period of time.
It's kind of insane.
But, but if you think about
the kind of science fiction
reality of us as technologists,
going to our business people and saying,
here's AI, go, go use AI and,
and make decisions.
Ask, ask questions on your
data and say things like,
make, make decisions that will
improve the business, right?
Make better staffing decisions,
make better pricing decisions,
make decisions that will
improve the business
in a meaningful way,
in a way that you
couldn't have done before.
And that's what AI can give you.
It's, it's finally,
it's finally accessible.
There's the big challenge there is that
you're still not able to use
AI connected to your data
in a way that you can trust, right?
So almost all of us would've tried
some kind of AI on data project, right?
You take an LLM, you
connect it to database,
MCP, whatever, whatever
connectivity technology you use,
and you can make it work.
But, but when you are on the business side
and you ask a question that is loaded,
the impact of that
question is pretty serious.
You, you know for a fact
that you're not going
to trust what it says.
And, and the reason is because
you know that it's gonna be hard
for even a human to
answer those questions,
but at least the human would
tell you that they don't know.
And if an AI tells you something
it's just extremely confident
and you have no idea
whether you trust that confidence or not.
If, if you think about
this ability that AI has
of just being confident all the time
and it's impact on
being confidently wrong,
that, that is kind of what
really hurts adaption as,
as you start to use it, right?
It goes from like a fun project to,
I, I can't actually trust
this to do anything useful.
Is this a, is this a better models problem
or is this something that we
can, we can do something about?
Can we solve this problem ourselves?
So I'm gonna share with
you our learnings as,
as we've kind of built an AI product
on how we tackle this problem.
And hopefully some of those learnings
are useful to you as you folks
think about your projects
and, and that gives you some ideas on,
on how you can tackle this problem, right?
How many of you listen to
the Dwarkesh Patel's podcast?
Do? Alright, cool.
Alright.
No, for those of you don't,
you guys should listen to
the Dwarkesh Patel's podcast.
It's got a bunch of bunch
of really fun stuff.
I think the most recent
one is by Andrej Karpathy,
and then by Ilya who was
the co-founder at OpenAI,
talking about a bunch of
topics around learning
and continuous learning
and utility of AI, right?
And, and this is,
this is something
that came up from his
blog post a while ago,
and I really, really
like this quote, right?
Which is that the,
the reason why a human being
is useful in your business
is not because they have 500 points of IQ,
because they win the IMO gold medal
every time you talk to them, right?
It's not that raw intelligence.
The, the raw intelligence kind of
was passed by LLMs a while ago, right?
So it's not the raw intelligence
that makes them useful,
it's, it's somehow this
ability that they have
of picking up context on the fly.
Of, of looking at a failure,
thinking about it and,
and fixing that failure, right?
It's, it's this ability of
like incrementally improving
that you can trust the human to do,
even though the human is not as "smart"
as DeepSeek V3 which just
won the IMO gold, but,
but somehow the human is
still more trustworthy, right?
And so this ability to continuously
absorb tribal knowledge and
improve is critical, right?
But, but this is,
this is obvious.
Like we all know that we want
AI to continuously improve,
learn tribal knowledge
and do whatever, right?
Our key, the key point
that I wanna share is
you can only teach something
when it says it doesn't know.
And that's kind of the critical thing
that's missing in AI products.
That confidence,
confidently wrong hurts you.
Even if AI got really good
at learning continuously,
the confidently wrong problem hurts you,
because if AI doesn't
tell you when it's wrong,
you can't teach it.
And if you can't teach it,
you can't use it.
And, and that's kind of
this core product loop
that's missing with AI products, right?
So let, let me, let me talk
about what we do at PromptQL
and show you a demonstration of
how we kind of approach
this problem, right?
Broadly, we're yet another
chat with your data product.
So, it's fascinatingly amazing and new
and differentiated with
everybody else here.
But the idea is to say that if users
are interacting with data,
they typically talk to multiple people
to get some kind of insight, right?
When you wanna solve a problem,
you wanna make a decision,
you're a business user,
you talk to an analyst,
you talk to a scientist,
you talk to an engineer,
they talk to each other,
they talk to data,
something happens,
some spaghettiness happens
and you get the result
at the end of the day.
Most often when you ask a question
you'll probably get the
result like two weeks later
by which time the question
is not very important, right?
And the promise of AI is
we'll have this cool AI
thing that sits in the middle
that users will use,
users will use that AI,
the AI will do everything
that the human does.
The AI will do data engineering
and it'll do data analysis
and it'll do data science
and it'll compose all of it magically
and give you an answer.
And by the way,
this might have sounded like
rocket science like a year ago,
but today you can see very clearly
that it's already possible.
You can take cloud code
and make it write a pipeline for you,
and then you can make it
write a SQL thing for you,
and then you can make it write
a data science program for you, right?
It's already in the realm of
reach, it's already possible.
The thing that's missing though
is that you can't actually
expose it to end users
in a way that they can trust it.
If you look at all of these
chat with data products,
ultimately they all turn out
to be text to SQL products
where you need the technical person
to look at the SQL to verify it.
So you can never give it
to a non-technical person
because a non-technical
person can't read SQL.
How do you trust it?
You, you can't trust
this AI system, right?
And so our operating model
is to get AI to admit that it doesn't know
so that experts who are
the red boxes can teach it
so that the AI gets better.
But most importantly,
because the AI can tell
you that it doesn't know,
even on day zero when
it's only 50% accurate,
it's fine, users can trust it.
Because if I can ask you a question
and you tell me that you
don't know, that's great.
I'll ask you two questions
and you tell me half the
times you don't know,
that's totally fine.
I can still use your product, right?
So I'm gonna demo kind of how
we do this in, in product.
This is the,
this is the core loop that
I'd like you folks to watch out for.
The first part is to tell you
what it knows and what it doesn't know.
That's kind of where this
cycle begins in the product.
The second piece of the
cycle that's critical is
that you can, once it tells
you that it doesn't know,
you can ask it to fix its stuff.
And then once you do, it learns.
That, these are kinda the three pieces
that I'd like you to
kinda anchor on, right?
Alright, so,
I'll do a recorded demo and
then I'll do a live demo
because like live demos
are fun and dangerous
and who knows if they'll work.
But let's say for example,
you ask a question on
what was GM broken down by
region yesterday, right?
What our system does is it,
first it, it does a plan
to solve the problem,
but you notice that it highlights
in blue links what it knows
and where that knowledge
comes from, right?
Internally, if you as a user
go click on that blue link
that is actually a wiki that
powers the AI internally.
This wiki contains
concepts like gross margin
that are pretty flexible.
Let me roll that up for you.
So the gross margin concept, for example,
says this is what gross margin is,
this is how you calculate it,
these are what our targets
are for this quarter.
These are what expected range of values
could look like, right?
And this is how you calculate it.
And so that's kind of a
wiki entry that backs this.
And, and you know, it's like,
just like a wiki,
there's multiple concepts
that are connected to each other,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
fun, fun, fun.
And, and that's kind of the core
piece of how it works, right?
But what, and,
and so this is fine,
we all have this today.
Like you have some kind of knowledge base,
you refer citation on the knowledge base
and you make it work, right?
What happens and what is interesting
is when it doesn't work,
so you say, what was GM last FY, right?
And here, the first thing
that the AI does is tell you,
well, FY it's this new thing.
It's a new thing that
I think in this domain
is a concept that is not known.
And that's, that's a red link
that it will make an assumption about.
And so it makes an assumption,
tells the user what the assumption is,
and then the user kind of goes on,
sees what the plan is,
looks at the answer, right?
And now as a user,
when I look at this answer
and I look at the value,
I'm like, this is fine,
but I also don't really know
what the fiscal year is.
This is the most common
thing you'll notice,
your business users will use the product
and they'll be like,
thank you for telling me that
you don't know something.
But true facts,
even I don't know.
Like I know we have a fiscal year,
I don't actually know
what the exact period is
because we are a global MNC and like,
is it different in different regions?
I, I have no idea, right?
And so this is kind of critical
where you now kind of bring in
another person into this conversation,
an expert or a group of experts to say,
can you, can you clarify
what fiscal year means?
This person kind of
joins our conversation.
This is an actual human being.
The human is an expert,
joins the conversation
and says, well PromptQL,
our fiscal year is whatever,
whatever, whatever.
And PromptQL is like,
cool, that fills my gap,
that fills the assumption that I had.
And it redoes the plan and
gives you an answer, right?
This was really important for two reasons.
One, the user is actually happy.
The user is happy that they
got an answer that was right.
Because they did something,
it was not accurate,
I brought in an expert and
I got the right answer.
This is what I would've
done even without AI.
I'm not, it's not surprising,
it's, it's natural to me.
But what is really nice is
that this entire conversation
has so much tribal knowledge
that just got captured.
This conversation is the seed of learning.
So now there's kind of another agent loop
that goes and helps
you create a wiki entry
and updates the Wiki
based on what just happened
in this conversation.
And because it's a wiki,
it's literally a wiki like a Wikipedia,
AI and humans can collaboratively
maintain that wiki,
and that wiki can kind
of keep getting better
overtime so that you can use it, right?
And then in the future,
let's say for example,
you ask a question and you say,
whatever Wiki, et cetera goes live,
what was the GM last
fiscal quarter, right?
That's kinda the key capability
where you also can
reference these advanced
kind of concepts in the wiki
despite what users are saying, right?
And this is kind of how you surface it up.
I'll take another example
to kind of show you
how we think about what
goes in the Wiki, right?
So this is another example of,
of a finance kind of data set, right?
Where I can say true north revenue for Q3.
Also for forecast Q4, right?
And, and you can literally
imagine what it's doing in the background
is it's kind of going here,
it's going to True North Revenue,
the Wiki article,
it's reading that,
and the Wiki article is
like literally just a wiki.
So it says, you know,
go to this table,
this thing is in Google Drive, it's a PDF,
you have to extract from a
PDF, like subtract adjustments.
What is an adjustment?
Go read up about an adjustment,
learn what an adjustment is.
Read up, read up about all
of these things, right?
And that's kind of what it's doing
for this first step of the plan, right?
In the next, in the next step of it,
what it'll do is it'll
try to read what forecast is, right?
And forecast is a wiki entry that says
do this data sciency thing.
These are the outliers
that you need to think about, whatever.
And these are kind of
progressively maintained.
You can imagine that these are sparse
and they get more and more structured,
they get better and better
as the knowledge accumulates, right?
Whereas initially it's just
basic revenue forecast use this model,
then later somebody used it and said,
Nope, black Friday, bad outlier,
please factor that in.
Maybe a data science expert comes in
and teaches that to you, right?
But that kind of powers the ability
to create an accurate plan, right?
There's kind of another
really important piece here
because the kind of uncertainty
and lack of accuracy
is not just semantics
and business concepts,
but it's also in the details of
fairly specific technical problems, right?
And so what we do is we also surface
the fact that the forecasting methodology
assumes that something
should be consistent, right?
It should assume that there's no refunds.
It is gonna assume that
there's no refunds.
Now, whether or not
that is important to you
is something that you can discuss,
think about, bring in an expert,
and they can say, yeah, you know what?
This assumption was good
or this assumption was bad.
Like, let's not do this again.
And so you teach it, fix it,
and again, kind of the
learning loop improves, right?
The way we think about our product
is that for non-technical
users we surface the wiki.
And for technical experts we
surface it in what we call
the confidence analysis
of the confidence score.
And, and, and users are expected
to think about the wiki,
and experts are expected to
look at the confidence score.
And that creates,
that creates the loop.
So that's, that's kind of a quick look at
at what this looks like.
The, what we've kind of observed,
and, and this is kind of our core pitch,
is whatever AI you're using today is,
is doomed for failure,
it will fail.
And the reason why it'll fail is because,
a you've, you've probably
not managed to get
a hundred percent of the tribal knowledge
into your AI anyway,
because how can you.
it's not possible if you are a business
of any respectable size,
it's not even possible to try
to embed that tribal knowledge.
And so you're doomed for failure because
not only do you have,
do you not have knowledge,
but you also don't have a system
where people can trust
what your AI is doing.
And, and what we kind of want to get you
on the path for is to say,
it'll always be inaccurate,
can we tell you that it's inaccurate
and then can we learn, right?
And so kind of put you on
this path of actual adaption
and that's kind of what's allowed us
to scale massively, right?
And it's allowed us to focus on solving
interesting technical problems.
Like, for example, the
fact that our AI system
is not restricted by
the size of the schema.
If you look at things like DataBricks,
Genie or Snowflake and Cortex,
they have, you know, 20,
25 tables AI on data,
who has 25 tables dude?
Like who's?
What enterprise has 25
tables that you work on?
It's, it's not, that's not even a problem.
Like that's not even real, right?
And of course it's a problem
because you can't squeeze
that much in context.
So we've kind of focused
on solving problems saying
a hundred thousand tables, 10,000 metrics,
how do you solve for that?
But you can only start to solve for that
once you fix the product loop of saying
whatever the size of your schema is
or whatever the size of the context is,
unless you have that
improvement wrong loop,
you, you can't even get to
those interesting problems.
But that's allowed us to scale
since we started early this year across,
across a bunch of really
interesting use cases
where there's a lot of high velocity
decision making that's happening.
Come stop by at booth #1733
if you wanna learn more.
We've got a bunch of tech folks,
we've got a bunch of sales folks.
If you wanna buy this and use this,
I will never say no.
But also if you just wanna stop by
exchange notes and learn,
please pop by and,
and we can chat more.
Thank you for your time folks.